lie announced hopefully by the
chancellor in November and what sort of
Hoops do you have to jump through to uh
to get them you've got to have
Partnerships with Pension funds to help
bridge that capacity Gap you've got to
show that you've got deal flow in our
case we invest with companies spun out
from Britain to universities and
Laboratories and you've got to show a
team with a track record it's putting of
all of that together on the basis of
what you've heard about this initiative
and you know we only know what's been
reported really in the newspapers thus
far do you think this is going to be a
success do you think what's what's it
going to achieve so the biggest risks I
think on this are the capacity we've
talked about impact we don't want more
money going into delivering fast food
faster that's which has been a lot of
written success so far in in our
unicorns which we're good at and then
the final bit is actually making sure
that we're linking it to companies that
work and spreading it out across the
whole of the industry here in Britain
and that we think we can do and and
other groups in our industry are there
you know Britain's actually got a fine
record in Venture Capital we we do
indeed and we have a great record in
startups the big challenge is scaling up
is this something that we're going to be
able to address through this initiative
I think so but we've got to make sure it
actually leads to real action that's why
ambition and aspiration by the biggest
groups needs to be matched with things
like the government's program on lifts
where they're actually announcing
something which is tangible with a clear
date so if the government can do that
then I think we're actually in a
position where these companies who have
got the potential they've got something
they can aim for and with that we and
they will invest in Britain's British
companies will scale up faster
sort of uh sums do you think are likely
to be decanted into these companies in
the outset well in Britain just around
the universities we think you could
deploy at least two to three billion
pounds a year now remember when we're
talking about five percent of insurance
company and pension assets that's 50
billion so it's you know that's 50
billion in total so in the smaller
sector that we're in universities and
Ventures there's a lot of money that go
in straight away but when they grow
bigger for example Tokamak energy uh
nuclear fusion that will require
billions as it grows and unless you've
got the insurance companies and the
pensions will be reliant on foreign
capital and The Sovereign funds who
we've been talking to already who are
quite happy to back Britain but they've
been saying where's the British money so
now it should come
let's hope so Douglas good to talk to
you today thank you my pleasure
some other business news stories for you
now and Thames water has today announced
its shareholders will inject a further
three-quarters of a billion pounds worth
of equity into the business during the
next two years that was less than the 1
billion pounds that the regulator off
what said last week the company was
trying to raise the cash injection comes
on top of the 500 million pounds that
investors put into the company in March
temp set a further two and a half
billion pounds would need to be raised
between 2025 and the end of the decade
well the news came as Thames reported an
underlying pre-tax loss of 82.6 million
pounds for the air to the end of March
that was down from a loss of
935.6 million pounds during the previous
12 months Thames also revealed that his
debt power Grew From 12.9 billion pounds
to 13.9 billion pounds During the period
BT confirmed this morning that it has
begun the search for its next chief
executive confirming a story broken by
Skies Mark clyman at the weekend BT said
that the current CEO Philip Johnson had
indicated he planned to step down at
some point during the next year he's
been in the role since February 2019 but
among those being tipped as his
successor at Mark Calera the head of
BT's consumer arm and Alison Kirkby a
non-executive director of BT who's
currently chief executive of the
Scandinavian telecoms group telia
EasyJet said today it was canceling 1700
flights during the current Peak summer
season owing to air traffic control
disruption in Europe the carrier said
the canceled France flights represented
two percent of its flying program for
July August and September and said the
majority of the cancellations affected
flights from its main base at Gatwick
Airport some 180 000 customers have been
affected by the cancellations but
EasyJet said 95 percent of them had
already been rebooked on an alternative
flight
that was just Monday we wanted to bring
you some good news your cup of coffee
should soon be getting cheaper the cost
of wholesale arabica beans has fallen
dramatically in recent months after
reaching the highest level in a decade
one of the biggest names in the industry
Lavazza is focused on one of its biggest
sponsorship events right now at
Wimbledon all of this made it a good
time to catch up with the company's
chairman Giuseppe Lavazza
first of all as a company we share the
same values of these beautiful Sports
it's a passion for excellence and the
challenge and strive Victory I think and
also the chance of discovering new Young
talents that's of course offer a lot of
new emotion to the crowd when they start
their career as for example a young
player as alcara it's of Yannick sinner
that not by chance is one of the Lavazza
Ambassador at the same time it's a very
good opportunity to showcase the
capability of Lavazza to set up a big
operation in coffee and offer is
about 100
000 of beautiful coffee cups and coffee
recipes to all the people that are
attending uh the Manchester
now it's obviously a very difficult
trading environment for Consumer facing
businesses right now how are you
navigating the inflationary environment
it's a very tough period of time and we
decided to try to absorb many of the
costs inside our margin to keep the
price as lower as possible and to pass
to the consumer a smaller percentage of
the bigger increase in the cost we had
over the last two years not only 2021
but even 2022 when it was a very
rewarding strategy for Lavazza because
we have significant growth in volumes in
all our geographies and of course a
reduction in our margin but we can
support that because we are not listed
so as a family company we can really
take for the long run I think the price
of green coffee beans is up by more than
80 percent over the last 12 months I
mean that seems to me to be a rise of
such a magnitude even you can't absorb
all of that and you have to pass some of
that on or is that the case
yeah of course we had to pass a sample
to the consumer it was impossible to
absorb everything but just to give you
the magnitude of an increase of cost we
had over the 2021 and 2022 we're talking
about
550 million euros in a company with an
ebitda of about 300 million Euros so
nearly two times our webinar so of
course was a monster maneuver to try to
cope with the part of course was a price
increase but very carefully manager the
other was of course the marginal erosion
and the third monitoring of operational
costs that's a the important part of our
reaction inside the company in terms of
your sales you grew sales last year by
just over 17 out of home was the fastest
growing channel for you is that been the
case this year
uh yes because uh uh by a good chance
away from home is recovering quite well
the volumes that they had before 2019 so
this is a very good news in 2022 for
example in UK we experimented the growth
34 in away from homes very very
strong to what extent is the fact that
the Eurozone is currently in a technical
recession having an impact on your sales
within the Eurozone or is coffee
something that people feel that they
have to buy regardless of the the
broader economic backdrop coffee is part
of the global economy so when
consumption go down even consumption in
coffee can go down that's exactly what
happened for example in UK in 2022 where
a coffee consumption went down 6.5
percent and the opposite our company was
able to grow 6.7 percent so this just
gives you the idea that if you manage
very carefully your prices
you can survive even in an environment
with such a strong inflation but of
course we're very concerned about the
future of the economy and the case of
recession is something they are looking
for with a lot of we pay a lot of
attention to that
now Britain's Canal network is at risk
of closures that's the warning today
from the canal and River trust the
charity that runs the 2 000 mile long
network of canals in England and Wales
it came after Therese coffee the
environment secretary announced that the
trust will receive a funding package of
400 million pounds between 2027 and 2037
on top of the 190 million pounds is due
to receive between now and 2027 but she
also said the trust would increasingly
have to move towards alternative sources
of funding well joining me now is
Richard Parry he's chief executive of
the canals and rivers trust Richard
welcome to you I mean this isn't a
surprise I mean when your trust was set
up 11 years ago the government said then
that you're going to have to rely on
Alternative forms of funding
yes and we've been very successful in
growing those alternative sources of
funding but fundamentally the canal
Network needs investment and whilst we
have ambitious plans to grow are the
sources of income it really depends on a
long-term partnership with government
that provides the investment that's so
vital to all the benefits that it
delivers economic benefits 80 000 jobs
we estimate depend upon the canal
Network all the health and well-being
benefits nature and biodiversity and the
business case for government to give the
investment that is needed is
overwhelming and the settlement
announced today would almost certainly
lead to the inevitable decline of the
canal network over the next decade how
far short Earth for your requirements is
the package offered by the government
today
well we're currently in a position where
our ground is not being inflated and
that of course is causing us quite a lot
of difficulty with the current rates of
inflation and what government's
proposing is not only to freeze us for
the next five years but then to reduce
problems uh in nominal terms so no
allowance for inflation we need a
settlement that enables us to grow the
income that comes from government whilst
we're also growing from other sources we
recognize that the long-term future has
to be to grow donations to grow support
from from businesses from members of the
public to do what we can to ensure we
develop a stronger connection with all
the communities around us but
fundamentally needs that level of
government investment to safeguard the
benefits that are so vital and of course
to mitigate the risk because our Canal
infrastructure 250 years old runs
through communities carries water across
you know from one side of the town to
another and if we don't care for that
infrastructure it could potentially pose
a threat to communities as well as
losing the benefits that so many people
depend upon Richard having read your
most recent annual report you've got
something like 232 million pounds worth
of industrial property another 144
million pounds worth of office property
you're not quite in the poor house yet
you could probably sell some of those
assets couldn't you well that would be
to take the very short-term approach the
endowment that was given to the trust we
were created was all about the long term
indeed we've had a very strict agreement
with governments to not use any of that
long-term endowment to fund the
day-to-day operation of the waterways if
we were to do that we'd effectively be
taking the income from the future to
plug the hole today and almost certainly
lead to an even faster decline in the
canals so we've had to be very strict
about ensuring that endowment is grown
for the long term whilst we secure the
income that keeps the canals open and
safe and available for the millions of
people who enjoy them every day all
right Richard we have to leave it there
I'm afraid good to talk to you this
afternoon thank you
still to come here on business live
we'll have a look at how the markets
have closed this Monday afternoon Stay
With Me
[Music]
well they've risen to 17 000 which is an
all-time high and we expect them to keep
increasing so about to about 26 000 by
2040 and what's behind it is is actually
really interesting because it relates to
social trends skin cancer takes a long
time to develop so what we're seeing is
actually the effect of UV exposure
potentially many decades ago in the 60s
as you said there was an increase in
package holidays a much lower awareness
that UV rays could cause skin cancer a
much lower sunscreen usage so these are
all factors and we have an aging
population so there's a bulge in the
over 55s which is also contributing to
the increase in natural numbers
definitely what we saw since the 60s is
there was a trend towards being tanned
being a positive thing and so
um but also sunscreen usage was much
lower than as you said so over the years
I think that's changed our
recommendation very much is for SPF 15
at the very least
and that's when it's applied
um regularly according to the
instructions generously some people
recommend SPF 30 as well to take into
account the fact that a lot of people
don't apply sunscreen as generously and
regularly as they should but they've
been really great advances in treatment
for skin cancer so now skin cancer most
skin cancers are just excised so you
don't require chemotherapy or
immunotherapy and often an outpatient
appointment as well we think about nine
in ten Cancers and nine in ten skin
cancers are preventable so they're
related to UV exposure so hopefully over
the very long term as sunscreen usage
become you know has become more
prevalent we would like to see that
curve curve changing but for now I think
people can be reassured that if if they
spot any changes in their skin do go to
their GP
um and actually if it is does turn out
to be skin cancer it will be very
treatable
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Fly Emirates fly better
[Music]
well European Equity markets have had a
largely positive start to the week uh
following us and weak inflation data out
of China overnight talking points this
afternoon include the German chemicals
company evonik which is off some one
percent in Frankfurt after cutting its
full year earnings out of the year old
the main European indices in positive
territory here in London the ftse 100 is
also in positive territory Ryan has
finished off uh just under a quarter of
one percent higher energy in consumer
stocks lifting the index the leading
gain in percentage terms is flutter
entertainment that looks like a bit of
bargain hunting after it hit a six-month
low on Friday among the leading fallers
is the property group land Securities
it's off by just under one percent this
afternoon on broker comment outside the
ftse 100 the online trading platform
plus 500 is ahead two percent on a
trading update while the publisher
future is up seven percent after
announcing a share buyback plan worth up
to 45 million pounds the legal services
provider Knights group is also ahead by
six and a half percent or so on a
trading update meanwhile the legal and
Business Services Group DWF it shares up
some 32 percent on news of a takeover
approach from the private Equity Firm
inflection valuing it at 342 million
pounds well on Wall Street stocks have
made a subdued start to the uh a busy
week in which inflation date on
Wednesday is the key release so you can
see it on the screen there JPMorgan
Chase both it and City are up ahead of
second quarter earnings on Friday on the
foreign exchange markets the main
talking point is the U.S dollar which
has fallen to a three-week low against
the Japanese Yen Sterling more or less
unchanged right now against the
Greenback the pound is off a quarter of
one percent against the Euro The single
currency meanwhile up a fifth of one
percent also against the dollar the oil
price meanwhile last week hit enjoyed
its best weekly performance since April
it spent most of the day in negative
territory but look at that it's just
popped into positive Charities more or
less unchanged actually looking at that
battle of Brent crude right now will set
you back 78.49 a barrel well joining me
now is Tom Stevenson investment director
in personal investing at Fidelity Tom
good to see you this afternoon
um let's before we talk about earnings
season which is crucial what about those
numbers out of China this morning
yes I mean it's a completely different
story isn't it from from from here in uh
in the west where we're so concerned
about about inflation they have the
opposite problem
um CPI actually fell uh producer prices
the factory gate price is actually
falling at their biggest rates for for
seven years now so I I think what we've
seen in the markets today we've seen a a
more positive tone to markets than we've
had in the last few days is actually a
reflection of that because I think
there's some optimism now that the
Chinese authorities are going to have to
start
stimulating the economy in a way that
they appear to have been resistant to do
so far in this post-covered period that
we've been through so China potentially
exporting a bit of lower inflation yeah
absolutely and and I think that we'll
see that
um later in the week and we've got the
U.S inflation figures on Wednesday
headline expected to come in at just
over three percent which would be the
the lowest for for a couple of years and
um so yeah I think that you know we've
turned the corner on the inflation front
almost everywhere except possibly in in
the UK of course yes well Andrew Bailey
is uh we've seen some comments from him
uh already he's speaking of mansion
house tonight he said he does expect
inflation to fall pretty substantially
in coming months we've heard that before
though haven't we well I mean the track
record of of uh predicting movements in
inflation is not good I mean I I seem to
spend my life going on programs like
this and explaining why inflation is
worse than we all expected it uh to be
but I think it will start it will start
coming down but you know the price that
we're going to pay for that is much
higher interest rates probably for
longer than we expected yeah and a
weaker housing market too absolutely now
earning season kicks off on Friday JP
Morgan and uh City uh kicking things off
what are you expecting to see yeah so as
usual the banks will start things off on
Friday I think I think this earnings
season is is really very important that
they're all important but I think we're
seeing a bit of a disconnect between
what's happening in the bond market in
terms of rising uh yields Rising
interest rates you would have expected
the stock market to have have not
performed as well as it has uh this year
so the stock market is looking forward
to better earnings next year and I think
that you know this earning season second
quarter earnings season is going to be a
bit of a down payment on that we're
going to see whether a bounce back next
year is is likely the expectation is for
a nine percent fall in earnings year on
year but if you go back three months ago
that's what we expected three months ago
with the first quarter earnings season
it actually turned out at minus three
percent so better so if we get a if we
get that kind of outcome this time I
think that'll be a positive for the
markets and I guess the banks are not
really the the best Harbor Insurance in
that respect because they're all going
to be doing very well because of the
expansion in the net interest margin
well I think there's a two-way pool with
the banks um the the expansion of the
net interest margin is a positive it's
it improves profitability uh for the
banks the Counterpoint to that of course
though is that I think we're going to
see an increase in Provisions against
Bad loans
um I think you know quite a significant
increase in Provisions probably the
biggest increase since the early days of
the pandemic all right Tom lots of I
wanted to ask you but we're out of time
I'm afraid good to see you this
afternoon thank you well that's it from
me I'm back again at tomorrow morning at
11 30 with the latest edition of
business live we'll have a bit of
reaction to that mansion house speech as
well I've no doubt thanks for joining me
today cheerio
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you